[Music]
Bruce Willis All Smiles in this
throwback moment I'm trying to let my
kids be kids as long as I can Bruce's
wife Emma shared the touching video to
Instagram Thursday reflecting on fun and
laughs with her husband
check out this recap of their family
trip to Disneyland Bruce is in total dad
mode using his arm as a seat belt
here we go
I think we're gonna go again
[Music]
and his oldest daughters rumor Tallulah
and Scout make an appearance too love
you Dad Emma caption the post quote you
bet this family will be back for more
fun and lives when you reopen as Tiana's
Bayou thanks for all the memories Splash
Mountain this comes after Emma's been
candid about the struggles of being a
full-time caretaker to her husband Bruce
since he's been diagnosed with French
Hotel temporal dementia I do have times
of sadness
every day a progressive neurological
disorder that impacts both cognition and
behavior because the emotional side of
loss and there is the other part of how
you're going to
write that wrong Emma Bruce's daughters
and ex Demi Moore revealed his health
condition in 2022 and last week his
daughter Tallulah opened up in a
personal essay for Vogue on life since
her father's diagnosis the Vogue essay
so beautiful the response I think has
also been beautiful what do you hope the
takeaway was for people from that
I mean the response has been so
unbelievable and I'm incredibly grateful
not only for the people that have
reached out but for Vogue and Anna and
Rob and everyone that was a part of
getting that
um
out there and for me I hope that
whatever anyone needed to take from that
they can take from it I don't I don't
necessarily want to dictate what they
needed to take from that I think that
that's their that's their truth and and
that I just hope that there can be more
moments that I can help open up the
space for things to resonate for people
what was your family's response when
they read that
they were very proud of me
I have to say it's really beautiful how
you all have walked through a very tough
time in your life is there anything you
want the world to
think about as you continue to walk this
path
as with every person and every moment
that there is
so much power and kindness and patience
and compassion
[Music]
thank you